I hate that you think that's a cowboy  hat you look like a Bushwick bull rider  like just get together with your friends  on a Thursday and you're riding the  mechanical bull and you'll do your  stupid  artisanal shots or whatever at the bar  at least cope with some cowboy boots I  did the best okay  um this is the best Cowboy I Could Be  Cowboys  remember that cowboy was like honey  where are my corduroys you don't think  cowboys wear cornrows I gotta go protect  the town my white quarterback call y'all  okay I'm doing my best you look like  Rango frog  this version of Toy Story would be so  much better if you were a woody but he's  just super gay  listen  listen  stop trying to make Disney games